và hôm qua đây, khi các bạn được chương trào đó,
sau khi các bạn sẽ về khoa của mình thì lúc này,
khoa cũng sẽ có một cái ngày nhập lợi các bạn,
các bạn sẽ được tiếp cận với bạn chủ nghiệm khoa,
các tài cô của vóng học tạo.
Lai những người sẽ đồng hành công,
các bạn trên xuất trận biểu của các bạn học.
Và, tại từ nó, các bạn là cái tụ sự khoa không dành được
khoa là một tụng phòng mà trong tạo hoặc quá nhiều.
Mà này là, phòng để giúp tình trận trúng ta có thể tìm càng và biết,
tất cả thành một sinh viên như thế nào.
Nhưng cái này các bạn được mọi lợi nó,
các bạn phải để các bạn ngay và các bạn biết được.
Tích miệm lợi và cái nghĩa của của mình trong những ngày mình,
các bạn có cái nhập.